well first up we're starting with the
incredible angela bassett oh i love
angela
i love her
so much
she is so amazing and she said something
that i happen to particularly grab onto
the legendary actress says there's one
compliment that you can just go ahead
and keep
harpist bazaar says she hates it when
people say you look so good for your age
um couldn't agree with her more but
in i always get because i don't know i
don't get the age thing but i get you
look so much better in person and i
think
thank you and then i'm like
what is my job of the hut on like you
know
my marty feldman am i a gargoyle what's
what's what's wrong with this what do
you think
and this is usually when i'm schlumpy no
hair and makeup so i'm also like oh okay
that's interesting i mean i think though
a compliment is a compliment i've met
angela bassa up close maybe the most
beautiful human i've ever seen right but
if the worst insult she's getting that
day is you look beautiful for your age
congratulations on your life because
that is not a bad thing to hear like i
will give me a compliment you can all
line up one by one and tell me that to
my face i will take it yeah you're right
and usually they're talking about what i
think is my best and seeing me at my
worst so you know what i'm just going to
take it as a compliment yes that's my
point
beautiful
yeah well next up we got a big workplace
experiment happening in the uk ooh i'm
excited about this one no mashable
reports 30 different british companies
are trying out something called a four
day work week and it's an idea that's
starting to catch on around the globe
they tried it in spain new zealand
iceland and japan microsoft tried out
the four day work week and guess what
productivity actually increased when
employees had a better work life balance
so drew
are we are we switching to four days a
week here
[Applause]
i mean i think we're a five day a week
show yes that's true yes um that's
probably not going to change however i
feel like this could really work in
people's
lives to have a better work-life balance
so i'm really excited about this i'm
glad to see productivity going up and i
hope this works because i would love to
see people have three-day weekends i
really oh please yeah i think
the audience is doing it i think it's
worth a shot and you look at
productivity
they tell you to have a better work life
balance and then we have hours of
occupation that don't allow for such a
balance so i'm very hopeful about this
we'll see how it goes and keep you
posted
[Music]